yeah i think like when it's j-rock absol
q and kendrick and you're the you're
like the first rapper i feel like that
kind of got
brought on after this initial success
no matter what you do you're going to
get compared to and critiqued and it
could could be to the highest level
um and like you know even like like you
know
with with reason you know like reason no
matter what like people compare reason
to kendrick i'm like they don't sound
the same at all but he'd be rapping
because he could rap just because you
know what i'm saying that's not a lot of
people can rap you know what i mean but
was that like that like how much of
getting over that hump
with the tde [ __ ] and just kind of
earning those fans where they saw you as
isaiah as opposed to like
um hey is this the new kendrick like how
tough was that i think it's happening
right now
do you think it's finally i feel like
right now like this album you're kind of
separate separation
yeah does it feel good i don't know what
it feel like i'd
i'd just be seeing it what have you seen
that's that's made you feel like like
like finally that moment's come
it's like the way people seem to
appreciate it and the way they come come
about it i don't even see people mention
them in my comments
like i'm sorry
i don't see people them like in a
comparison way in the comments
where i'm sure previously that probably
happened a lot it was like a lot of
kendrick sometimes rock but like that
was it
and it was but it was light though back
then so i knew that they had
appreciation for my music then but like
now it's like this is me